if you wanted to destroy the most
powerful military in the world what
would you do well among many things you
might try is hosting drag queen story
hours on military bases for kids and
today Congressman Matt Gates who
represents maybe more uniform military
than anybody in the Congress confronted
the defense secretary about it directly
watch
how much taxpayer money should go to
fund drag queen story hours on military
bases
yeah
you know drag drag queen story hours is
not something that the department funds
wait a second that's actually not what
the record seems to suggest you were
going to fund one at Ramstein Air Force
Base that one got canceled but that's
DOD Insignia that's a drag queen Story
Hour for children then also at uh
malstrom Air Force Base outside of Great
Falls Montana you had a drag queen Story
Hour for kids who funded these things Mr
secretary listen uh drag shows and are
not something that the Department of
Defense supports or funds
yeah a liar
board member to defense contractor
before he got this job uh so then Mark
milley the chairman of the Joint Chiefs
admitted that he was not aware military
bases were hosting drag queen story
hours watch this can I get copies of
those because I'd like to take a look at
those myself actually take a look and
find out what actually is going on there
because that's the first I'm hearing
about that kind of stuff I don't read
those news stories I don't know what
you're talking about I'd like to take a
look at those because I don't agree with
those well they're now I think official
records shouldn't be happening thank you
thank you for that admission
yeah actually you'd like to go you know
so I'm trying to open minded guy uh Matt
Gates represents North Florida in the
U.S Congress even if he never passes a
bill it's worth having him there just
for moments like this it's just amazing
what was your being on the questioning
side what was your feeling about their
responses America's top military leaders
have brought misery to almost every part
of the globe they have touched they put
Iran in a position of power in Iraq they
armed Isis in Syria they turned over
Afghanistan to the Taliban in the
bloodiest way possible we could have
taken out the suicide bomber didn't give
the authorities they didn't even get the
Vengeance part right Tucker when they
were supposed to take out Isis they took
out a family on the way to a barbecue
and so now you see them trying to bring
the misery and the ruin home to our
country through this Embrace of
diversity equity and inclusion and this
is real money 70 million dollars they've
requested for enhancements to diversity
equity and inclusion and this is the
most divisive stuff possible and when I
showed the Secretary of Defense evidence
that was happening in Nevada in Montana
in Virginia he just said nope it's not
happening and it makes you wonder do
these people have any sense of reality
or is the pain the point whether it's
Dei or the vaccine mandate that they
still don't have good answers for
but in the end it means that nobody
wants to join the military in their
recruiting numbers are dangerously down
do they see a connection between their
Reckless crazy behavior and the
unwillingness of people to join up
voluntarily we are in a recruiting
collapse and they say well we don't
think Dei is the problem because we've
sent out surveys and no one says it's
the problem they don't realize that the
people offended by this conduct aren't
going to take their stupid survey let me
just be honest a great set a great share
of the people who fight in our military
come from the American South and when
you Embrace these values that are so
antithetical to the part of the country
I represent you are really putting a
downward pressure on the people we need
to volunteer and fight not for some far
away land not to go build some democracy
out of sand and Arabia but for our
country and you have to wonder whether
it is incompetence or a purposeful Purge
I also pressed them on making sure we
get our service members their full back
pay and restoration of rank Austin said
he would not do that in the absence of a
legal requirement to do so so that is
precisely the amendment I intend to
offer to our National Defense
authorization act yeah when you say you
hate white men you do kind of Wonder
like who's going to fight the wars then
because that's who's always fought the
wars well General Millie maybe didn't go
to the drag queen show because he was
too busy getting in touch with his white
rage still who knows but he gets credit
for saying he wants to shut him down
loathsome mackates thank you so much
appreciate it thank you subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube channel to catch our
nightly opens stories that are changing
the world and changing your life from
Tucker Carlson tonight